you two are phenomenal in this movie you
are also surrounded by an incredible
ensemble and I want to make sure our
viewers know as many of them as possible
give you some high school superlatives
right now and tell me local we did it
which one in real life not the character
okay Amelie teachers or maybe in this
case directors pet me family so that's a
good one Mason yeah who plays Knick
directors pal
I mean Noah God that who plays George he
was the most eager beaver and the most
amazing person because he gave us so
much extra he was always available to
give us a new button for the scene to
stay late and shoot another piece
he was so available creatively and I
just am so lucky and thinking I would
love to call him my pet the class clown
class clown Niko Harada underpriced
tanner he is a professional skateboarder
bride trade this is his first film he is
very silly and hilarious and I love him
very much
classic Noah got no government ya know
what
or just bill or Skyler oh oh boy Billy's
like such a classical yeah Billy Laura
Billy Lord non-galvan or Skyler
next up light for the party life of the
party Billy Lord who plays Gigi she is
not as wild as Gigi is she's a very
professional smart person and she is
very smart as well but Billy is on
another level of fearlessness and I
would party with her any day biggest
flirt biggest flirt that's really funny
um skylersays and oh who plays Jared he
doesn't intend to but he's just so
adorable you can't help it he's just so
lovely and I think people will fall in
love with him in this movie every time
it's I hear his name now my heart breaks
a little because they cancelled santa
clarita diet but it's good that makes it
more available for more babies so good
she's so good in that show Best Dressed
before getting into wardrobe
um Eduardo well let's say I mean it's
between Eduardo Billy and they're all
have great great style I have to say but
oh you know what
Victoria ro Eska who plays Ryan in the
film she's a pro skateboarder and I
loved her look so much that I asked her
to just wear her own clothes in the
movie so so she's really just wearing
all her own stuff most likely to be
President Mary Gordon yes Molly Gordon
Triple A okay my best friend in the
world oh well I think beanie Feldstein
would make a great president and I think
she is most likely although we have a
lot of candidates in this cast but I
think beanie is one of the most
impressive intelligent hilarious warm
people I've ever met in my life
most likely to drop his or her cell
phone in the toilet awesome nico nico
yeah no Nico's a good one to end on a
high note
most likely to brighten your day Katelyn
Deaver is I mean they all are honestly
as an ensemble they all are but but
Kaitlin is a very special creature and
she worked so hard on this film and I'm
so excited for people to see her comedic
side she is just astonishing she's my
little Julianne Moore that's what I see
for her and she always brightens my day
Victoria Victoria soz but all of that
Mason I mean everyone's so sweet on this
movie yeah Victoria has a very special
energy that's like so happy adhering
yeah